partir ou rester le dilemme des
snowbirds cet hiver certains sont
déterminées à partir forme a dit qu'il
faut il ya quand même nous on prend
l'avion comme s'expose et puis on rentre
au camping on va confiner leurs deux
semaines comme s'exposer le couple
possède une résidence sur un terrain de
camping acapulco au mexique ces
déplacements essentiel quand même aller
voir ce qui se passe à notre maison
ottawa recommande de vérifier auprès des
autorités de leur destination
les restrictions en vigueur
josé lussier elle via l'année dans son
véhicule récréatif
elle reprendra la route peu importe la
destination et on essaie de trouver
quelque chose à vancouver mais je pense
qu'on est pas les seuls à avoir un plan
b
les terrains de camping sur l'île de
vancouver c'est complet
mais tous sont d'avis que sans assurance
médicale couvrant lakovic 19 impossible
de partir depuis le 21 mars le canada
les etats unis le mexique demande à tous
leurs citoyens d'éviter tout voyage non
essentiel
si vous partez malgré la recommandation
du gouvernement
vous êtes vous courez le risque de ne
pas être assurés pour vos soins de santé
point donc ce n'est pas parce que la
frontière est ouverte pas parce qu'un
pays vous accepte que du point de vue de
l'assurance pour les soins de santé que
ce soit votre assurance individuelle ou
collective que la situation va changer
quand même quelques compagnies offrent
une couverture médicale pour lakovic 19
dont la croix bleue et midi pack
assurance voyage chez changement majeur
et pour contacter certains croient que
ça coûtera loi mais moi monsieur
pour ceux qui décideront de rester au
canada les clients qui est motorisé
quelque chose comme ça lui peut
s'installer fait chauffer il peut fermer
le sauveront va commander déjà le cse
accommoder des snowbirds comme hélène
qui troque son vr pour une mini maison
sur le camping dans notre corps on met
le vr à vendre pour le moment
on le sait qu'on voyage repos pour un
montant que tank est question de
convives de on veut pour voyager un
choix déchirant pour ces accros du
soleil ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada
hemmingford